you're competitive obviously we raced
against each other you're ultra
competitive and you get super sonic
pissed off when you when when things
don't go danica's way that's i like that
the most about you because i like
getting pissed off when things don't go
my way when was the time that you feel
like you let it out the most and paid
the biggest consequence you know
probably the only time that i ever
really let myself go that i didn't like
i didn't care like i was so pissed off i
didn't even know my helmet was on put it
that way with ryan newman after the race
because honestly it scared the crap out
of me after the race it's over and i'm
taking my belts off like i didn't even
have seat belts on and he hit me and it
spun me head on into the wall i mean i
wasn't going 180 mile an hour anymore
but i was still running probably 70. i
lost it next thing i know um some crew
guy has a hold of me and it's got me
clear off my feet and i was like rock em
sock them to ryan newman through
through his window now like i didn't
even know what was going on i was so mad
it was you know that's that's race and
that's competition right
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
on the show today is my very good friend
clint boyer uh he's a retired nascar
driver and we were teammates at the end
and god we just had like okay so if you
don't know who clint is you're going to
want to get to know clint let's just
start off by saying he's like bffs with
blake shelton so that's the kind of guy
that clint is he's awesome he's funny
he's he likes to drink you know he's
he's a lot of fun um but he also has a
lot of passion and he accomplished so
much in racing and now he's commentating
but we just you know we talked about
nascar we talked about what racing's
really like he told so many funny
stories and we talked about just you
know the future of the sport but in a
really holistic way like things that
could apply to any job in any business
any entertainment sort of uh company it
just was really it was a really cool
conversation and clint is just hilarious
all along the way and this is one of
those that he he could be a comedian
basically but instead he drove race cars
and i'm grateful because he's my friend
now and yeah we just had a really good
time so please enjoy this interview with
my friend clint boyer i have i have a
new
motto mantra for myself but the old one
was try harder which is essentially i'd
say try harder do better
um now my saying is
oh well
[Laughter]
i like that one
yeah i will oh well something happens
i'm like oh well
it's su it might be the most helpful one
i've ever had because i don't really
have a problem trying harder
i have a problem letting things go so oh
well helps me let things go
so you're competitive
well
obviously we race against each other
you're ultra competitive and ultra
competitive and you get super sonic
pissed off when you when when things
don't go
danica's way that's i like that the most
about you because i like getting pissed
off when things don't go my way
it feels better it does yeah it's an
expression of what's cooped up inside
you just gotta let it out when was the
time that you feel like you let it out
the most and paid the biggest
consequence you know probably the only
time that i ever really let myself go
that i didn't like i didn't care like i
was so pissed off i didn't even know my
helmet was on put it that way and
with ryan newman after the race because
honestly it scared the crap out of me we
got together in a racetrack and things
happen right well what track
at charlotte
and i am literally after the race it's
over and i'm i'm taking my belts off
like i didn't even have seat belts on
and he hit me
and it spun me head on into the wall i
mean i wasn't going 180 miles an hour
anymore but i was still running probably
70 you know and smoked the wall and spun
back around and i was like literally
didn't even have my my anything on
dude
i lost it i i went completely
out of my mind and and last next thing i
know i'm i'm literally some some crew
guy has a hold of me and it's got me
clear off my feet and i was like rock
him sock him to ryan newman through
through his window now like i didn't
even know what was going on i was so mad
it was you know that's that's race and
that's competition right
that's the moment though you asked the
question that's the last got away from
me what was the one because i love a
good fight and i love i love it and when
like when there's a red flag and you're
still on track and there's a fight that
breaks out you know because the crowd
gets excited and the one i'm thinking of
that has an awesome clip that's turned
into a total like meme gift for you is i
think it was phoenix well i know it was
phoenix and you running through the from
the from pit lane
through the garage were you chasing
jeff down jeff gordon yeah my
counterpart and now you work together
what happened well the first day back on
the job was a little bit awkward let's
just go ahead and say that but
we had to get past their differences but
there was a lot of differences right
there but at the end of the day we both
knew that that was going to be fine but
that was
what did he do to you he wrecked me now
i i he calls it retaliation i call it it
was it was that aggravation and and you
know he wrecked me after the actual it
was during the race
it was down to the crunch time in the in
the playoffs and we were racing for a
championship and
you know that was the next to last race
so we were down to
a lot of money on the line a lot of
business you know there so uh that one
was that one stung a little bit that one
hit the old pocket book and when that
happens that's a whole nother level of
pissed offness is that a word was that
is that what makes you the most pissed
off the funniest part about that story
was
we were supposed to
leave there things were good we were
flying to l.a to uh to blake shelton's
house
and he was uh who was we you and jeff no
me and laura my wife laura yep awesome
awesome we're flying to l.a
and we're going to go to the voice it's
her first time she's a huge john levine
day she wanted to meet him right so
really wasn't about any of us it was
about that we get there blake wants
nothing because he's a huge smart ass
like i am he doesn't care about anything
other than what happened on on the race
you know let's let's
by the time we land in l.a he is on a
twitter war with all of the universe
all jeff gordon fans it's like little
video clint's fan base and jeff gordon's
fan base it's been in a sport for 50
years you know it's like he is in a
fight with all of them including ingrid
his wife i'm like
what are you doing no stop
so
that happened we end up getting through
that and that was probably the most fun
thing about it it was that night
afterwards is seeing how much
satisfaction and enjoyment blake got out
of the fact that i got wrecked on that
racetrack
um
yeah
yeah yeah it's good to have friends in
high places
it wasn't that was a pretty low place
for me right there i could tell you that
you were low but blake you talk about
your you know fan base and jeff's and
then blake's see i don't see that i see
him being
an oklahoma boy i don't see this la guy
that everybody else sees i see the
redneck from oklahoma but he kind of but
he lives in l.a part of the time right
yeah
yeah
kind of
sure i don't like that blake l.a blake
is it's different blake l.a bike is is
is you know
hair done and and weird clothes on i
like camouflage blake that's that's the
blake i like camo blake do you find that
do you find the the clothes that you'd
like to that you normally see blake in
down at uh what's your favorite store
that you go to every time you're home
true blue blues [ __ ] something
there you go
what did you did you ruined my profile
how did you remember bluestone that is
the best store ever ever it can fix
anything but a broken heart in the moon
i'm telling you right now if it can be
fixed
it's gonna happen at bluestone because
there's everything from what to what
there it's got a wall of wranglers 500
feet long so you got close it's got a
bootleg it's got work gloves it's got
cattle shoots it's got feed it has
hydraulic oil like bolt bin galore
anything that you need to fix anything
dana can see that that picture on the
wall you hung it with blue stem parts
and pieces that that behind you was done
at blue stiff that i'm telling you the
gamut whether it's danican scottsdale
arizona or [ __ ] clint and emporia
kansas i'm telling you it can be fixed
it sounds like you could fix a broken
heart there though if they sell beer and
fishing rods and guns seems like you
could just sort of take that out there
into the world and and get better it's a
great point because my heart does feel
better every time i go there just makes
me feel better about myself it doesn't
matter how bad a day it can be fixed at
blue stem go blow four or five hundred
dollars at blue stem the day is fixed
where do you get all this humor from
clint i really want to know let's unpack
your childhood we're going to go going
to unpack my childhood yeah i feel like
it's in there somewhere i thought this
was a podcast not a psychiatry you know
i don't know
it's both you won't know the difference
though
man i don't know i i grew up as a middle
child um you know the biggest thing with
our family is no different probably than
yours we raced non-stop we didn't
sometimes do anything else you know we
tried to do the
you know stick and ball stuff my brother
played some basketball um
we i i went to football i guess at camp
the first day is that camp before you
know school starts with all my my big
corn fed buddies go into football camp
i'm thinking man i want my pads i want
my helmet i mean i'm ready to go i'm
gonna be a football player right
probably yeah you're not big enough to
be an offensive lineman anika this is my
story you asked the question i'm telling
you
so so here i am thinking i'm gonna have
my own helmet right can i have pads i'm
gonna be the man the coach and i will
never forget this this is my football
career in one day nutshell story first
thing we do walk in the door and he goes
all right boys run to mcdonald's and
give me a a a big mac and come back i'm
like
you mean
the mcdonald's in town it was six miles
into town he made the football team run
run
to get him a sandwich at mcdonald's and
back
oh clint didn't have that in him i was
like man this ain't for me no helmet no
pads and running nah nah nah nah i'm
gonna go back to uh to race and
motorcycles so that was my football
career um tried basketball still not
tall enough you know so it was
motorcycles for us we actually my dad
owned a towing service
and tony reynolds a guy that worked for
him
um back in you know the day
raced motorcycles he had a practice
track behind my father's
shop in his towing business
and we used to go back there i mean
little little i remember watching tony
ride you know his motorcycles back there
i'm talking before pw 50s so santa claus
naturally after we were watching tony
rides here comes
you know
santa claus brings us pw 50. which is a
tiny little bike right it's like a
little
everybody's introduction 50 you know 50
motorcycle forever i mean my god it's
things still exist and the part number
is exactly the same from 1981 that's how
good of a problem
oh my god
but there are people listening that are
probably living somewhere like
california or you know new york and they
don't know well they got to use electric
ones now i don't even think they allow
anything gasoline out there anymore you
can't even have a gasoline lawnmower in
california anymore what kind of fun is
that
zero i know i hope they run out of
battery use a generator to start it
i'll loan them one so anyway here we go
we're going racing we have a tractor
tire that does everybody full of sand
that was our sand pit where we're old
enough now that we have motorcycles
there's no reason for a sand pit anymore
we built a ramp over the the tractor
tire
the rest is history man we were off
motorcycle racing and and having a blast
doing it as a family like i was saying
and traveling all over the place
the one thing that was instilled in us
from an early age and you don't know it
until you get older is is the work ethic
that your parents put forth for you to
have this opportunity in your career
and it happened for me you know once i
had kids i look back now that cash is
racing late uh uh go cards and i'm like
dad what in the hell were you thinking
i mean
we were racing 13 hours away in lake
whitney texas on a sunday afternoon just
an afternoon race just a summer shootout
race every single weekend 13 hours away
we would wake up in grade school parking
lot
walk straight into the the school and go
to school he drove all night long all by
himself did it every single week your
dad drove then right he was strong
what do you live off of because i'll
tell you what my dad lived off of
because he did something similar too
what did he take what did he eat or
drink to stay alive for those two my dad
always ran you know he had a towing
service that's 24 hours seven days a
week doesn't matter if that phone ring i
honestly just think
he
conditioned himself to do that like he
literally would drink some coffee every
now and then but nothing usually nothing
just wow well my dad was just on pure
crack he was on mountain dew mountain
dew and sweet darts
i'm telling you like he it was a beast
when it came to that like you know when
we grew up we had you know as people had
phones in your house remember those
remember that phone number right yeah i
bet yours was long go hide around the
corner how long the court did you have
dude i had so many dads of course yeah i
had so many boyfriends i'd have totally
have i have a long cord boyfriend called
you're on 100 foot cord out in the
backyard in a shed
from the living
room so we
sang i love you no i love you i love you
more i love you more i love you the most
i love you infinity those kind of
conversations when you're like you know
12. yeah i didn't have those we were
racing so anyway we had a line in our in
our house that was line one was home and
it had a different ring line two ring
you knew what that meant as soon as you
heard that in the middle of the night
you'd hear dad stomping down the hallway
going to toe some drunk out of the ditch
at 3 o'clock in the morning and
probably wasn't even gonna get paid like
he always did that so that work ethic
was was there from the beginning for us
and and honestly that's what i think
kind of what what made us who we are you
know but but you asked me why i guess a
sense of humor just being on the road
having nothing else to do than just pick
on one another you know when my old man
and i are together everybody's like
what the hell's going on do you guys
hate each other you're like
[Laughter]
what are you talking about this is our
love language like you you guys are
cussing each other and
but he hasn't left yet you're like
that's just kind of the way we we i
don't know that's how it works
so
we've we've always had a lot of fun and
it always you know usually was going up
and down the roads you know racing and
god so many stories you know like
my older brother let me tell you a funny
story yeah i should probably shouldn't
even be here so my brother was had his
learner's permit which i think in kansas
you could get at 14
right
so
the old man was working a truck wreck
the night before here we are headed back
down to texas and we had a winnebago now
we're big time right we had like
time three i think it was a little we
had a van
yeah chieftain 33 winnebago
we were i tell you how big a deal we
were we were in the back this little
girl had not one bed you know it had two
like little single double whatever they
are in the back but we were playing
excite bike i will never forget this the
day i died me and my buddy were playing
excite bike remember that game pretty
much
nintendo excitebike you kidding me i
played track and field and duck hunt i
didn't play
side by side it's cool that's the excite
bike excite bike
it sounds
for a boy who loves bikes anyway we're
racing motorcycles we're playing side
bike going down the highway dad falls
asleep lets andy drive 14 years old
[Music]
and he's got cruz set in the old
winnebago here we are next thing i know
like you're jumping jumps and
it wasn't the motorcycle jumping anymore
it's the winnebago jumping we go
barreling down through the median boom
boom
boom back up on the top the refrigerator
flies open a whole bowl of chili
mom-made force flies out of the
refrigerator all over the floor broke
the glass pot
that's fine
i tell you how hard we hit it true dad
out of the passenger seat
on the floor he looks up there's
headlights coming so he freaks out grabs
a hole the wheel and pulls the thing so
here we are bounce through the ditch and
i mean jumping through the ditch it gets
calm right it's like all right i think
everything's fine next thing i know nope
wasn't enough we're on the wrong side of
the road dad pulls the wheel back over
the ditch we go all the way through the
whoops like we just went through hell
and back we get back on the right side
of the road and by this time all of us
are on the ground the tv and
everything's off excite bike's gone
we're like what in the hell just
happened me and my buddy go running up
front
dad is on his knees he is on his knees
driving the motor home andy is freaked
out with his eyes this big
finally get this thing stopped my
brother freaks out takes berlin out
right out the door and we're running now
we're like the clamp it's out on the
side of the highway
running from my dad
like clear over by the fence on the on
the highway like
what what happened
so andy fell asleep we had deal
winnebago was ghost riding is what i'm
trying to tell you
so then we had like a family huddle
right so what do we do do we turn around
we're freaked out we're scared
everybody's scared but everybody's okay
you know we go back and check the ever
the load out in the trailer bikes are
fine nothing's really crazy there so
dad's like well you boys want to go
racing
kept going baby
oh my god that is spectacular no no
never having wild stories on the road i
mean there's no food left but go racing
why not chilly and by the way
a hell of a mess don't have anything
really
in a refrigerator in a motor home just
for that very reason yeah that sounds
like it would be an absolute awful job
that i'm sure you boys had to do
do i have crazy stories like that no
like i don't my sister and i just
cuddled in the back of the
truck we at first dad had a truck with a
little extender cab on the back
and then we got a van so the extender
cab was either way too hot or way too
cold and brook and i would lay up there
and sleep a lot and then um and then we
got a van and uh we called it the fun
van because all the fun's inside
and uh it had an electric back back
bench that laid down to a bed it was
electric pretty cool
and there's a tv in the middle so we
could watch movies and headsets on each
side i mean it was 20 minutes that's
like a conversion van
well it was a real van i mean it was one
of those giant electric couch that's
like that's a high-end deal
well it wasn't a winnebago though
well i mean this is true this is true
so no we just cuddled and and and you
know dad dad's fiery so sometimes there
was some crying going on after races but
um
what kind of role did like like ichi you
know all the brothers like what what was
what's the personality of each
so
well andy was like my older brother was
the one that
by all rights we all thought was the
super he was the superstar when we grew
up he was the baddest i mean we all know
ricky carmichael who that is andy beat
ricky carmichael in a national event
loretta's in an amateur national like
he was good really good you guys were
all good i mean you were a kick ass
dirty danny was extremely good you know
and really stood out and especially in
the midwest and and you know i mean
was awesome he got hurt he got behind
and
the difference between motocross racing
and car racing is practice you know you
can practice every single day on a
motorcycle and you get better you know
and you really don't have
that element that you have in cars where
a lot of times you're only as good as
your competition or your equipment sorry
you know you're only as good as your
equipment you're sitting in i mean you
can't if that thing's not there i mean
you know we've lived it you know if if
that if that hot rod is capable of
winning you're gonna have a chance of
winning if it's not
you're gonna do all you can do to get
the best finish you can in a motorcycle
you really don't have those things it's
all just your natural ability and your
talent um you know that carries you
through that being said andy got hurt
and it really set him back he couldn't
ride he couldn't practice for that you
know six to eight weeks whatever it was
in the meantime all this competition was
every single day grinding it out you're
farther behind
now you get back on that thing what do
you do when you're behind in a race car
as a competitor
you overdrive you drive it harder and
next thing you know you're on your butt
again and you're hurt again now you're
even farther behind then you're farther
behind you just can't catch up and and
honestly that's what happened to him he
was he was
really really good had some injuries got
him behind and just never could catch
you know up again but at the end of the
day the industry was good to him he he
wrote a lot of articles for racerx met a
lot of good friends with the fox family
and heck he lived with john fox for a
long time you know so he had a lot of
good years in him in a motocross world
loves that industry we're all still
connected to it pretty well um but you
know that was that was andy's story he
lives in florida he got two little girls
and and things are fine
but
again we thought he was gonna be
you know the superstar
[ __ ] clint was working at a goodyear
tire store
in emporia kansas because i didn't know
anything else to do my boss was building
a a chevelle and i mean
a boat chevelle like i think it was a 76
i'm talking boat um it's way too long
we go that we went to the junkyard got
an engine out of the junkyard by the way
yeah
not like bob's racing engines i'm
talking junkyard john's engine out of an
old malibu or something put it in our
chevelle we go to the racetrack i'll
tell you what you do with it you blow up
and it grenade and time and time again
we come back
we did that so many times i remember
coming back in on a friday night and not
even getting back to the shot we go
straight to junkyard john's and get
another engine take our heads and our
intake carburetor and put back on it our
head headers by the way is a big deal
back then
put it and we go back racing saturday
and did that time and time again next
thing you know i'm like man i want to
drive this thing one time let me drive
and and again the rest is history that's
what really kind of catapulted so it
made you want to drive cars instead of
bikes no yeah dude i was going to those
guys i mean what did you not like about
this there was there was a good race
which is you know we're competitors
there was a hell of a party and a lot of
good-looking girls i knew you were gonna
say girls and if you didn't i was gonna
ask i'm in baby that was exactly what i
was looking for my whole life
off to the races we went and never
looked back
unless she was cute
then you look twice
oh my god let's talk about what racing's
really like what do you mean i don't
know i think there's probably a
perception of you know i don't know i
don't know what do you think the
perception is i feel like you know you
and you could sit here and give us some
you know tell people what it's really
like out there what is it really like to
be a race car driver talk about like
car versus
driver and like that's the age-old
question right and i mean i know my
answer but you know what the heck's it
really like to be a real race car driver
my wife actually asked me this question
racing for a hobby is a lot of fun
racing for a living
isn't fun at all it's a business
you know when i raced in in the cup
series
very very seldom
was i truly having fun unless you're
staying in victory lane now that's
always fun that's the goal right that's
the the day's end goal on sundays is to
be in victory lane but honestly if
you're not in victory lane it's not fun
it is it is very challenging it's hard
work it's
what you've invested your whole life
into and it's very serious and that's
the way racing was for me you know
i was very very seldom in a race car
ever out there you know everybody thinks
i'm just happy-go-lucky and and wild and
crazy not behind the wheel i was always
you know very very serious and didn't
didn't enjoy
um
the actual racing until it was over with
and you could get back with your friends
and stuff like that that doesn't mean
that i didn't always want to be at that
racetrack and
more importantly be in that race car
that was where
i guess my favorite place to be but when
i was competing for a living on that
stage
it wasn't fun for me it was dead serious
and and i met every minute you know
every minute i was there if you wanted
to be if it if you say that it it's not
that you didn't want to be there um but
that wasn't necessarily your fun then
what was the driving force
i mean there has to be more than just
competing man it's always about
competition you know
like did you like passing did you like
practicing and making the car better oh
my god did you just ask if i like
practicing there is nobody in alive in
in the human form that likes practicing
no possible chance now you like
practicing i just didn't like it when
there was three day practices those were
terrible
practices six laps and
yeah oh oh it looked like it was a
really big handful man thanks for not
crashing my car yeah thanks for trying
to kill me i'll bring it right back here
hey by the way make another change so
let's go try it again that was fun let's
go do that again i like it over and over
for three days when they make really big
changes and then they're like hey we
just want to try this concept oh yeah
like just the concepts never hurt that's
never a good terminology with an
engineer let's try this concept the code
feel it out was like hey this might be a
bag of [ __ ] but just like you know try
not to crash it but we want to try this
how do you feel something out in a race
car by the way in our cars the only way
they make grip is to go the speed that
they're designed to go so if you're if
if that thing's supposed to run 190
miles an hour and you're running 140
feeling it out it doesn't have any grip
so you have to go out there rifle that
thing off in the corner wide ass open
and go past the feeling out point the
only thing you're going to feel out is
your ass when it hits the wall as hard
as it does at 190 mile an hour that's
what you feel out then you get back
there and look at them cross side and
they're like
super sorry about that man i sure hope
you you're okay you're like yeah i guess
i will be next week yes that didn't work
yeah no [ __ ]
sherlock the way those happen we've all
had those oh yeah yeah yeah i feel like
it was again on the feeling out or or
you know a science project or something
like that
but on those you always feel bad for
that guy too because he's the one that
made that call and you'll come back in
and
you know you see that guy and he's just
like
heads like
i'm so sorry man are you okay so i
always kind of felt bad for those guys
too yeah i guess adding 10 pounds of the
leftover didn't work
well it did till it didn't
yeah um so yeah but like what like more
about it like i feel like people just
it's hard to know about racing it's hard
to know what it's really like and you
know maybe even just like we could start
with like whether the car versus the
driver and
i always say that you know the drive the
car the best driver can't win with a bad
car but an average driver can win with
the best car
oh yeah absolutely and and that's that's
just spot on you know i mean i think
that's gospel as far as i'm concerned i
will say this and i don't want to go
away from thinking or push people to
think that i didn't enjoy myself out
there now the one thing that i did enjoy
more than anything
was passing people
it takes a lot of a lot of discipline a
lot of focus a lot of you know learning
studying somebody watching them make a
mistake pushing them to make that
mistake right putting that pressure on
somebody there's nothing more fun in a
race car when you're driving somebody
knowing that they're looking in the
mirror and they keep driving it off in
the corner harder and harder you're like
don't do it don't do it they drive it
off in there and next thing you know
they're sliding up the track and you got
them you know that's the best feeling in
the world being behind the wheel when
you force somebody else to make a
mistake because you were that much
better than them that day that's a cool
feeling so those days and those
circumstances in a race car were things
that i really did enjoy but
um you know the difference in the
drivers versus equipment
i think that's evolved too danica i
think when we first started or when i
first started
you know you had 900 horsepower that
thing would bite you yeah
i was trying to tell me my dad was
telling me that i was around in the 900
horsepower days but i was like i don't
know i thought it was more like 700 but
my dad has better memory than me when
did i drop down
i mean my first year was in cup was 2013
really i would say 12 12. i think it was
like 14 or something 14 or 15.
so
you know
but i mean you're not 200 horsepower out
of cars i mean a lot of people that are
listening this podcast that's how much
their car makes totally
you know they took that away
so the difference in driving styles you
know i really look at like a tony
stewart or a jimmy johnson they weren't
quite as immortal you know when those
things happen they came from no
different than me massive horsepower in
a dirt car a little bitty tire you know
so you were always driving that thing
with your foot you know and not
necessarily steering it with your foot
all the way on the floor today's day and
age you're wide open especially on a
mile and a half track you're literally
wide open all the way around and if
you're hung out or loose or anything
else it's not because of the adjustment
in your pedal it's because you're
steering the thing and you've got it
loose with your chassis and you're
having to keep up with it with the input
in your hands
that was something that really really
you know made me struggle with what i
was trying to accomplish behind the
wheel of a car you know when i couldn't
no longer balance the car so to speak
with my foot with the throttle um
it made you you know change everything
that basically you know that was
instilled from you from the beginning uh
and how i grew up and i believe that
tony stewart was the same way and jimmy
johnson again you put those guys back in
them fire breathing dragons and 900 950
horsepower
they go right back to the top i was
sitting in my office and i looked over
the reason i said that i was i have 80d
but i think i did i've never been
diagnosed but i'm pretty sure i do
jimmy's picture from eldora is on the
wall right behind you
and
i remember him getting in that car and
everybody thinking which i owned we went
to eldora he got in a dirt late model
and everybody including my brother like
man i don't know what you're thinking
here i don't know he ain't never been in
one of them i said watch he'll be the
guy to be
got out there that picture right there
is him and me standing in victory lane
it wasn't me that wanted it was him
i knew it like it's just that was that
when i raced against him in the cup
series him hanging that thing out and
using that throttle pedal to balance
that car it's what he's good at does
that come from dirt racing though like i
feel like i'm more off i drive off the
steering wheel and
not on the throttle so is that more like
pavement versus dirt
i definitely think it's a grip thing you
know dirt you're never gripped up ever
you're always sliding around on top of
the racetrack so you're balancing you
know that ball you're balancing that
thing um with with your throttle you
know a lot of times you're driving that
automobile with with the throttle and
the brakes way more than you are the
steering wheels yeah
yeah i mean i coming from go-karting and
indy cars like i definitely drove off
the steering wheel more but yeah i mean
racing's just you know it's one of those
things it's like you know it's it's
you know the
biggest stupidest thing i ever said
um
stupidest thing i ever said is that the
indy 500 it was qualifying and it was
the first year i wasn't like in the top
10-ish basically and it was a struggle
like real struggle bus like i was
shaking when i got out of the car
because it was four laps on the
knife's edge which is not how you want
to run at indy flat out
or four laps which is two and a half
miles each lap which is 10. um
and uh and i got out of the car and i
said i said it's not my fault
i never lived that down man i heard that
at indy for years and years to come not
my fault not my fault but you know at
the end of the day it's like you know
the conversation we're having is that
it's if the car is good it's easy that's
the problem wait wait i mean you're only
as good as your equipment and that is
true
like
the best driver in the
prime example is kyle larson we both
love him 11 to death i love what he
accomplished this year i it was
record-breaking literally
record-breaking
but a lot of my friends that don't
necessarily know about racing
took to him i introduced him some of my
nashville friends like dude he's he's
killing it man our friend kyle like
you know all of them started calling me
like hey mccool's personal close
personal friend kyle larson i'm like
dude [ __ ] no what are you talking
about you know but that's they took to
racing because of kyle mcguise he's been
racing for five years in the cub series
nah nah nah nah this is his first year
like no no he's been around a long time
the difference is he's in different
equipment
that proves the point and it's been
proven time and time again but it's not
a knock to people either there's a lot
of effort there's a lot of
um
you know there's just a lot of
infrastructure differences through all
the manufacturers
yeah it plays right into the lap of of
said manufacturer and that comes you
know in cycles we all know that and
especially in our sport um
and but the brute honesty is it's all
about people it's always been about
people and no different in any other
business or any other thing in life
if you have the best people surrounding
you
you're gonna look the best and that's
just the way it is you know kyle larson
has had the best team and the best
organization the best manufacturer this
year around him and
you know all the ingredients were there
and he put it together and was the man
you know and that's why i was happy for
him i think it was a timing thing and he
couldn't have timed it any better he
nailed it yeah it was cool to see too
after all of his struggles and
you know being out of the car and coming
back but
what do you think like i
i feel like i made
my probably my biggest mistake in racing
was
not spending more time with team
guys with
you know i just like for me it just
i look back and i'm like it wasn't fun i
didn't like hanging out the shop i
didn't like you know i didn't and also
like either they were really old or
really young and it's either you know
you're not gonna go out to dinner with
some like it's inappropriate or it's
just like i have nothing in common with
you and so i don't know i look at it
like that's probably where my girl the
girl in me showed up a little bit it was
just not like if it was a group of girls
i'm sure i would have made friends with
them but i i that was kind of my regret
and i feel like that
not a regret but that's something that i
could have done better is get the team
to work around me so
like how do you create the environment
because you can have super talented
talented people but they're not inspired
right you can have talented people that
are not
putting in the right effort and so how
do you like what do you think is a as a
common theme with the years or the
teams and groups that you've had the
most success with well i mean i think
for you it was different i mean it just
was you know you were an attractive
female recently you just said it if
you're out with a young engineers you
guys are dating
automatic you know and the worst thing
about racing is how tight a circle that
is and it like literally oh my god
heavens forbid if you even get caught
talking to somebody like it's it's on
it's done it's official you might as
well put it to record books they're
they're full on dating and and that's
just the way it is so i couldn't imagine
of doing you know what you did all those
years being you know the female that you
were and ultimately it was you know a
pretty male dominant sport
um
for me though
it was always about that that was the
most fun you know my most fun memories
of before i got to nascar was driving
all over the country with the boys and
the truck you know the dually and
trailer and learning life and the life
lessons miss screwing up putting the
wrong fuel in the truck and being broke
down on the side of the road and trying
to pump that out oh [ __ ] don't tell dad
you know or or get off somewhere and we
about burn a motel down one time with a
bunch of guys we got drunk in the
parking lot started a guy's car and got
thrown out i mean like those are the
memories that like
you know you just can't replace but once
you get to this level and it's
professional side of it it was still
that way for me i had to have fun with
my guys and everybody had to have fun
the best year i ever had was in 2012
back to that that incident with jeff
gordon that you were talking about at
the end of the year
we kicked ass we were really fast we
were knocking on the door for a
championship right down to the last race
of the year
and
took care of business but i'm telling
you
nobody and i mean nobody ever had as
much fun as we did doing it like it was
dangerous to go the track because back
then not only were you doing it you know
on on you know friday through sunday we
were testing all the time we'd leave
sunday and fly to
you know everybody always says why do
you why do you idiots have your own
planes i'll tell you why because when i
started if you ask wanted to be home at
all ever during the week you better have
a plane or access to a plane because you
would leave sunday and fly straight to
another track somewhere in the united
states you would crack or test there for
two days and a lot of times you may go
to another track and test there before
you go to the next week's race wherever
that was like we were
all over the place that year and i'm
telling you in and out of cities that
we've never been to before having fun
and
that was a really really good time so
you know it's it's it's different
obviously you know you ask the question
but those are the memories and things
that i guess i was good at you know i
could make sure we may have a bad
weekend but i can make damn sure that
boys had a good time doing it um yeah
that's amazing yeah for sure you are and
you are
you are a
freaking good time like i have no doubt
that like being on you have any idea how
bad the headaches hurt anymore being
that good time
when everybody expects that out of you
it's dangerous as hell i just want to go
to bed anymore and then what happens
when you and blake are together i mean
what happens is there have you ever had
to have your stomach pumped
first of all he's like 14 feet tall and
he's it's not fair like it's not the
same fuel tank you can't put it right
here buddy same liver you're [ __ ] i
disagree with that there's no way a
human that big has the same liver as
mine and if his has to be enlarged it's
i'm telling you right now it has to no
it's shriveled it's there's nothing left
of it disagree disagree
if you ever
hung out with him a day you would you
would agree with me it's there's
something different there
wait clint are you drunk during this
interview
no i'm drinking water just kidding i may
have put vodka in it but
that would be more fun i swear this is
copy
no we've had some good times that makes
total sense i mean my best year was
probably 2009 in indycar
and my engineer my two engineers um
we didn't have we we we didn't have like
a crew car crew chief we called them
engineers in indy car and so there was a
head engineer an assistant engineer and
um we just had a freaking blast we
laughed all the time we we just had so
much fun we gave each other so much [ __ ]
all the time
and uh that was my best year um and um
funny how that worked yeah it's true
it's it's been a hard it's a hard and
hard thing to execute like how do you
make sure that happens you know that's a
that's not an easy thing and i think
that's probably why it's hard to make
the magic happen no matter what sport
you're in speaking of sports from kansas
how are those chiefs doing
rocky road but that's chemistry what
you're talking about that's what that is
and it's hard to find and once you have
it it's hard to keep because everybody
else as a com you know when you're in
competition and everybody sees that and
realizes that
they need it you know that's what
happens in racing i see chemistry over
there with danikan or two engineers well
that guy's an assistant if i can make
that assistant
the main guy
pep him up a little bit i'm gonna pick
that away i'm gonna take away and knock
them down a little bit
that happens in racing all the time you
know it's very very hard to keep that
chemistry keep that team you know under
the same umbrella because next thing you
know somebody's pulled one piece of that
puzzle out it's just not the same yeah
that's right thieves god almighty i
don't know i went to nashville
i don't know if you watched the titans
game
we got our teeth kicked i want a bet
with kid rock
and i got his sweet over there so like
he was supposed to he bet on awesome
you mean
bob
bob bets on
he
we were at his bar and he's like it was
the it was the night before the
nashville race this year he was going
out there he was excited and you know we
were having a good time he's like
just awesome doing
10 grand austin dillon wins the race i'm
like no chance austin dillon wins but by
the way
i'm not taking your money and as soon as
i said that [ __ ] you what do you
mean you're not too scared to bet me i'm
like
no i don't want to take your money like
it's not going to happen it's just not
in the cards i love austin dillon it's
not the cards right now it's not going
to happen have you seen kyle larson how
fast he is i mean like if he gets
coven doesn't exist like i can't come to
the racetrack this week it's the only
way you're gonna not be you know he's
not gonna win that being said bob listen
to me he's not going to win
get your hand out right now so i shook
his hand and i said tell you what
we'll either
no cash either i'll pay you the 10 if he
does win or
you take it out of the bar bill here
or
chiefs are playing soon i want this
suite at
the titan stadium
naturally i got the the sweet right roll
into bob sweet man it's nice booze
everywhere if things are good brought my
whole friends everybody i mean we're
rocking and rolling chief
you come in all your friends were there
well i mean i don't know where you hide
anymore like you're in the mountains
here in the desert i'm not coming out
there to the desert blistering my ass to
drag danica fine whatever keep moving
story story story i drank a little
listen so we go to this this game got
our cheese stuff on you roll in as the
opponent i mean you gotta write you talk
to [ __ ]
we're talking more trash to fans down
below and we're gonna kick your ass and
yada yada we're cheese
i mean loud and proud baby
it was the worst game in chief's history
we got our teeth kicked in from the word
go
oh my god it was bad
it was the only game i've been to all
year now i'm scared to death now we're
coming back i was in vegas two days
before they just played the raiders and
i was so scared to stay because i was
like i'm going to jinx them i have to
leave i can't watch the game i want to
stay but i'm not
left wanted to see that new badass
stadium didn't see you
flew all the way across the country home
watch them win so right now i don't know
where the hell we're at we're high we're
low we're everywhere
patrick decides to show up and throw a
good pass we're good if he throws 17
interceptions again we're gonna
it's just that
simple young young hot gun you know they
just throw the ball and
lob it up
usually it goes where where you think
it's going to go here this year it's
been like
you know a left-handed pass all those
cute things he's always done you're like
hell yeah man my boy he knew what was up
he did that on purpose
now you're like man i don't know maybe
that was just a little like yourself do
you have baby brain
no
no actually i think his uh i'm just
kidding he's a freaking but i think his
knowledge of of what's going on in his
surroundings his situational awareness
is just insane you know i think he sees
things that other other guys don't see
or sees it before them and that's where
he's always ahead but man
you know i think you're only as good
again it always goes back to the people
we talked about this you know i i don't
know that his entourage is as good as it
was you know we've lost a couple weapons
a couple of receivers and uh some
protection on the front line like you
you start taking that one piece that
engineer that assistant engineer left
anika that chemistry wasn't there
anymore you know it's so important to if
you do lose it you got to figure out how
to make it back the way it was yeah
what's that what do you think that is
well right now it's some uh pass
protection and uh maybe
that is the that is the hard thing honey
and i think that's kind of like the mark
of an incredible
um
you know athlete all around us when you
can kind of start keep recreating magic
um because it's really hard other than
you know stumbling into the right
situation whether you're a driver a
football player or a baseball player
it's uh
you know it's all right
i guess and i hate to give it to him
because he's such a badass and everybody
knows it but the biggest thing about
this guy that i'm gonna say and i'm
gonna say his name tom brady
the biggest attraction to him
is
the fact that he did it he he pulled out
of all that chemistry all that stuff
that everybody said that man it was it's
what made him who he was belichick you
know all the stuff right
pulls out of there it goes into a
complete new environment that's a ballsy
move
you didn't have to even spring training
that year you literally didn't have to
do that you know he was going to go off
into the sunset in the record books
probably never been be touched again
he goes
challenges himself to try something new
knocks out the park and wins another
damn super bowl like
how gronkowski just re raking it in you
know but i mean it's again he he took a
chance and made something else you know
built a whole new chemistry and and he
did it himself you know so
i love that that the fact that he did
that i think at his point in his career
most most competitors in any profession
would would not do that wouldn't take
that gamble because
at the end of the day your legacy is
kind of on the line you know and and i
was he still the the baddest quarterback
of all times yes but if he went
somewhere else
and failed for two or three years he
almost kind of murkies that diminishes
that for a while until time will catch
back up
he didn't he went down there and took
care of business and i wish he'd go off
into the sunset already because i'm
ready for somebody else
that's the biggest thing about tom brady
it's not tom brady it's his damn fans
those oh
there's nothing worse than a patriot fan
god they're they're just
very cocky
i grew up in the midwest so we also had
a
we had our choice of who we thought the
worst fans were living in illinois but
anyway um
uh it reminds me of almost like
schumacher did you watch the schumacher
documentary
you know my son cash and i did and it
was probably the only time
well i've let cash watch a documentary
but
the only time he didn't
you know deter off of it he stayed right
there and watched every had a lot of
questions well wait a minute rewind that
rewind you know like for a six-year-old
to do that
it was pretty intense and and what uh
what a story what a career what a level
of intensity that was
unmatched really well i mean he
recreated at ferrari you know you go to
a team that had
was terrible and he turned it around
just by sheer will and being around and
present and getting people i always say
it's like getting people to work out of
fear instead of
getting people to work out of love
instead of fear it's like you can get
people to do a really good job out of
fear they're afraid they're going to
lose their job but the difference
between
that and love is the next level and when
you don't want to let your it's like if
you're it's like a dad working on your
son's go-kart you know like you don't
want to let your son down but now if
you're just a paid employee like who
cares you know cut a couple corners
whatever you know
you're just it's just you know it's not
the same thing and so when you can get
people to work out of love like their
family then and they really care about
you and they don't want to let you down
to me that's that's what it is and so
when you talk about like having that
chemistry with people and getting along
it's it's like this applies to any job
any sport any job when you are all like
in such
care for each other and you have fun it
means you don't want to let each other
down because you know you're you're
you're more than just co-workers you're
more than even friends you're like
family oh absolutely
go takes me back to 2012 with that year
that we had i mean that's the way we had
each other's back you know if if i
wrecked they'd pick me up or if you know
if i made a mistake in the car they
picked me up it was a bad pit stop i
mean you literally
he felt bad for the guy because he felt
so bad
but you said it back to him
it's also confidence that's a level of
confidence even in the professional
sports
that is very seldomly seen like that
level of confidence is is
i i wouldn't have done that
you know i had a i'm a confident person
and i was a pretty confident yeah you
know i was confident in what i did
behind the wheel and in a race car but
if i won four or five championships and
i had to start over from scratch again
at that point in my career i wouldn't
have done that i'd just been like man
i've made enough money and and why why
chance it you know those guys
they did they challenged themselves they
wanted it he literally said it in that
he wanted to like he wanted that
challenge and he wanted it on his
shoulder he wanted that that weight on
him no way who's got it you think any
you think any other who what drivers
might have it in nascar at this point
um
nobody
but i think that here's what is
happening in nascar that i really love
i just watched brad keselowski's uh
press conference you know as an owner in
a sport love that he's doing that that's
absolutely good for him i love that he
is a highly intelligent guy brad's got a
lot of [ __ ] going on brad's a big deal
his cam industries thing i went over and
did an interview with him this year and
i'm telling you right now danica he's
probably going to be the most
the wealthiest race car driver that ever
came through and it won't be of course
it's because of his car he couldn't
afford it to do what he's doing but i'm
telling you what they're they're
building rockets sweetheart i'm talking
building parts that are going to space
oh that's a different level you mean
literally yes oh i want to go do you
want to go if you could go to space
would you go if they said you could go
to the moon or bars
why would you do that
well
because i want to see it
what do you
but you like to see weird [ __ ] like i
don't i don't like to say they are going
to see it there you're going to see
everybody down there having fun that's
all you're going to see now you're going
to want to be down there which one is it
you know me i'm just a superhero
oh you like the stars and planets and
all that you want to see them all that's
what you want to do i want to come back
in the next life as a cosmologist
dude i like i like
my feet on the ground that's what i like
i get scared
that's way too high up there
but uh no let me let me finish on brad
and what's kind of changing of the guard
you know there's a lot of owners that
are getting up there in age there's a
lot of concern a lot of talk a lot of
what if so like what's gonna happen you
know what yeah all of them all the big
ones you know joe gibbs is is getting up
there uh rick roger penske rick hendrick
you're starting to see a changing of the
guard jeff gordon he quit me i didn't
make it would i make it four months with
him and he already quit out of the tv
booth and he's winning wait he's done
dude he sucks what a wuss he went back
that's right that's right and then i
texted you and i'm like what are you
gonna do without
jeff i don't know we had a lot of fun
i'm kind of bumming me to come help you
you can i i need help yes lord knows i
need help i want to go do f1
oh
why bother with last little peons i'm
going to go do f1
so
there is a changing of the guard jeff's
gonna you know going to help out and
probably assume the role of of you know
running hendrick motorsports um someday
you've got brad now taking the role at
roush jack roush that we just you know
one of the ones that are that are
getting up there danny hamlin's starting
his own team you know i think this is a
timing thing and it's really an
interesting thing that these guys
because that's a gamble it takes a lot
of confidence that's a lot of risk right
there getting out past your skis like
there is a lot on the line to take in
that chance and and i applaud those guys
for doing that because i think the
rewards there in the end i think the
sport is is going in the right direction
i think the rta and what they have going
on is in the right direction for our
sport
um it's rta for someone who wouldn't
know well it's basically a union an
owner's union like you have in football
or any other you know sporting event
nascar didn't have that it was the good
old boys the good old boys and their
drivers and we come to town and put on a
show there's the purse you take your
little calf we'll take our cut and they
take a little bit we all go on to the
next one did you forget what happened
when
um in the open wheel side of things
championship auto racing teams when it
was cart and all of them everybody had
to say so and you know everybody was on
you know all together and then they all
just went
and
the whole thing dissolved those things
have wings those are space shuttles i
don't agree these aren't race cars they
have there's some space shuttles
yeah but it's about the
business of it
and i think it's dangerous when you get
too many people involved that um
that are powerful and and
because they want their
perspective and their opinion to be
heard and executed and when you get too
many head honchos in a room
shit's going down or or not at all you
know when when it's when when people
aren't heard and you can't hear all of
them so it's dangerous but you know well
there's certainly
in in sports there's
there's the product
right the the product and then there's
the competitors who puts on the show
you know in football it's the teams well
those teams are worth something you know
and
and the way it was in our sport those
people that put on the show for the
product
you know they they didn't it wasn't the
promoter the promoter showed up we'll
simplify this the way it was back in you
know friday night lights under the
lights at lakeside speedway that
promoter would he'd give you the track
you know and you would have to come on
and put the show on for them for doing
so you got paid you know your your
payout right you got paid in victory
lane you got the payout back on back
that's how you made your end work
in our sport the owners they're that
product they have to put it on the on
the table so
you know the sponsorship side of it
because they're on the track because
they're in front of 100 000 people
they're on tv in front of millions of
people that that product is worth
something so they're able to sell that
the point is
football has the same thing eventually
you got to figure out some structure to
be able to have a viable business you
know and and when it goes to sell say
these guys are getting older what are
you selling
before if they didn't form some sort of
a union like that you're really selling
bricks and mortar and whatever your
trucks and trailers and your jack stands
are worth that's about what you got
you've got millions of dollars worth of
an entity but if i'm coming to sell it
to somebody
like what the hell are you selling right
yeah that's there's your hot rod it'll
be out there on sunday here's your
sponsorship this is the way it works but
i don't know you have to go talk to them
and see if they might buy into what you
guys have they they i don't know i did a
lot of business with them and
maybe you can make it work too
so
again you got to have a viable business
that you can with a business plan that
you can hand somebody that's worth
something that makes and props up our
sport to where the whole sport is in a
better
well-explained flint yeah but i mean
that's that's the truth you know and i
think that that it is in a good way and
it goes back to what i'm saying about
the opportunity and the timing
standpoint of these drivers getting to
the back side of their careers having an
opportunity to fill that in because by
the way you need some youth you need
some some new eyes and some new vision
some new enthusiasm to be able to prop
this thing up into the next decade
what do you what do you think could make
it better i know that like you know one
of the things that we've chit-chatted
about is just you know especially when
you and jeff were you know doing it last
year it's like what could be better like
what could we do to make the drivers
more attractive and people follow them
like what what are you quitting
way to go
but i quit yeah you said what can we do
to be more attractive you quit
is what can you do i think we're doing
it i think that i was excited to go to
new venues when this thing was really
going like this in the 90s yes dale
earnhardt was the baddest
guy ever right everybody wanted to be
dale earnhardt what rusty wallace mark
martin toughest little race car driver
in the world like those guys were
genuine and bad asses and they really
dale jarrett they took this sport in the
90s to the next level because of
i and the other thing is you can relate
to them the relatability
anybody any blue-collar working-class
human being could look at that guy and
go that's my guy he can be right here in
the body shop bending on his fender
painting and spraying the thing like
he could just as easily be doing that
with me as being in that race car for me
on sunday like that connection that
relatability was so important we've lost
that a little bit but the other thing
that we they did in the 90s that we're
starting to do again and where i'm going
with this is going to new venues being
in front of a new audience
showing your audience that you already
have something new where it's not so
repetitious of the same thing over and
over lap after lap after lap year after
year where boys are coming back to town
you can only sell that so long before it
gets stale
it's true you have to reinvent yourself
and and sometimes
venues do go stale
things of all people evolve
like look at the difference a phone has
made in somebody's life like you can't
get anybody to do anything anymore
like you go to dinner with somebody and
i challenge you to go through an hour
and a half to two hour dinner and not
touch your phone
watch i mean i've been texting the whole
time since we've been doing this
interview
it's probably everybody's saying stop
shut that idiot up
no way but i feel like
you know for our sport to get back
to where we were and trend you know the
way they were in the 90s um we need to
do that and we are doing that the la
coliseum what an awesome kick ass
opportunity the excitement's through the
roof i'm gonna be able to call it um
we're going to a running track literally
in a coliseum these cars have never done
that
it's gonna all hell's gonna break loose
it's gonna be completely chaotic who's
gonna win i'm telling you right now
anybody's game
anybody's game can win that race because
whoever is leading on the last lap
they're not going to win no no chance in
hell they're going to win and it's not
going to happen they're going to get
wrecked they're going to get out they're
going to be pissed off but everybody's
going to erupt it's going to go crazy to
be controversy in the track they'll talk
about it for months that's the kind of
stuff that takes you to the next level
and i will say this and i'll give it to
credit ben kennedy's the one
he's the family you know at nascar to
like he's the next one talking about
changing of the guards this kid is
family france family and he's taking it
to the next level he's taking chances
that that you know maybe others that
were running the sport couldn't do
you know he's taking those changes and
taking the lead and and it's a gutsy
call going back to the conversations
you've had about certain you know
competitors i mean that's a gutsy thing
to do with pull out of something that is
that you're steady right to go and do
that venue to go take that chance and go
somewhere else that means you got to
take something from somebody old place
has been good to us but we're going to
take that race and we're going to go try
something new that's a gutsy call and
it's going to be
something that i feel like in 20 years
gonna look back on and really really
appreciate and say that was a difference
maker yeah wow damn your wealth of
knowledge clint what tracks need to go
like maybe the second pocono and the
second
none of them
i agree with you and that's a funny
thing none of them need to go
some of them need to be
put away for a minute oh put away put
away
you know and i know that that's a that's
a scary thing to say
but
you know i do believe you got to move it
around you got to shake things up if
things aren't working at a you know a
second race or wherever
you know
so be it but what makes things work
isn't always that product on the
racetrack how many football games again
went to the titans game i say titans
game because they kicked our ass chiefs
versus titans i was a cheese fan
literally she socks underwear pants
shirt hoodie hat i'm a cheese fan tmi
very clear that i was for the chiefs
we sucked but i had a good time doing it
yeah there was a hell of a party going
on it was atmosphere there was things
alive didn't matter how shitty the game
was that's the point in that you have to
have environment those tracks have to do
a good job of working in the in market
you know with with the people you when
you come to town i don't care where it
is you got to be the number one thing to
do in that town and if you're not that's
maybe when it's time to put it on the
back burner or try something else go do
something else to where you are the
number one show in town whether it's 20
year old kid or a 60 year old man
you're going to that come hell or high
water you're going to buy a ticket
you're going to sit your ass in the
stands or wherever it is you're going to
see that go down because that's the end
thing to do for that given weekend
you've got to go back to that mentality
and we were there for a long long time
there's a lot of venues that we still do
and just kick ass in and you see people
having fun and i'm not driving around in
a golf cart i'm loving it i'm like that
is fun if i wasn't out here in this car
or up there in that booth talking about
these idiots going around in circles i
would be out there being an idiot in my
winnebago cheap in 33 with bush lice
drinking beer with my buddies like that
looks like fun that's kind of chilly
because you can't always prove my point
is you can't always count on that
product providing that entertainment
that's next level
that's competition sometimes it's there
sometimes it's not it won't all a
rivalry game or a rivalry race that's
not always going to be what everybody
expects it to be yeah
that's that's how it all you gotta have
atmosphere man you gotta have things
going on because that's what props it
all up and makes it happen yeah i
actually looked at myself like that
i looked at myself like
i'm not always gonna have a good day
but what else can i offer a sponsor what
else can i offer
my fans you know there there's got to be
more to it and i always felt like you
know at least from a sponsorship
perspective like they were they were
winning no matter what you know they
were they were getting a getting a
really great product no matter what and
then when i did well it was like icing
on the cake you know if it's a great
game if it's a great race whatever it
may be it's just icing on the cake it
should always be it should always be fun
though so do you have so many good days
in your life of danica world that you
you have to punish yourself like run
cross state lines to to
to make yourself have a bad day is that
is that why you run and work out and
because you just you have so many good
days you want to have a bad one just
make sure your things are balanced out
why would one do that you know clint
some people like practicing in racing
and some people like working out you
know nobody likes practicing nobody ever
in the history of practice
there's no one
if you're telling me you enjoyed
practice
we have no no more in common no chance
in hell wow just when i thought this
when i was gonna invite you to a big
party i was gonna have you know i
thought that was more common than i
thought maybe i should
[Laughter]
you should be the you should be like the
entertainment director for nascar they
should be like clint
what should we do that would help people
have more fun at the racetrack i mean
would you not have the answer
well definitely i mean i've got a lot of
a lot of opinions and honestly we've had
a lot of conversation with that but i am
a believer in the fact that you got to
have that atmosphere to help prop it up
on your bad days yeah you know there
can't always be good days and and when
they're not if you do a good enough job
of building and creating that fun
atmosphere
that won't always be that way i'm a big
thing i've always said this about any
anything any venue you go to
if you're going to charge admission and
charge money for a ticket
i call them wow factors and i feel like
there has to be
for you to go to an event whatever it is
football
a competition
for it to be classified as something
that you come back and tell your dad or
or your your girlfriend jogging or
whatever the case may be you're going to
take something from that venue bring it
back and you're going to tell that story
god oh my you should have seen this you
should have seen that i call them wow
factors and in my opinion a race has to
have five if you don't have five wow
factors within a race whether it's
it's a a gutsy call whether it could be
something as small as that whether it
was a wild wreck unfortunately as long
as nobody got hurt whether it was a
crazy finish or
or
a fight who knows but i feel like you
have to have five you have to check five
of those wow factors off for that to be
a success for that event to be something
that bob goes back to the coffee shop on
monday and tells his buddies you cannot
miss this again next year it was holy
[ __ ] crazy fun those five wow factors
some of those are out of your control
though could you apply those to like wow
one of the wow factors could be a
concert before the race it could be ah
you brought that's my point
because you can't bank on it being a
good race you might be at a
you know you might be at beautiful
kansas motor speedway where aerodynamics
is really important and they can't be
close enough to each other to really
mess with each other so it's not that
exciting yes that's what i'm saying
opportunity goes back to the coffee shop
didn't see it on the racetrack this
weekend maybe last weekend he did but
this weekend he saw danica next door and
she was in a chieftain winnebago
motorhome having beers with her friends
holy [ __ ] you got to be there next year
like
again it doesn't always have to be that
product on the racetrack but it better
be more often than not yeah
i feel like there's like this is cool
you know i feel like you know you
retired and
you you went into commentating and what
i hear from you now is like commentating
is sort of probably pretty easy and it's
a lot of work in a different way but
it's pretty natural probably and but
this is like a conundrum to figure out
this is like a mission and i don't know
i just feel like a fire within you
around this like this is perhaps your
next
your next job essentially is how do we
how do we bring this sport back to a
place that you know
was was reminiscent of um another phase
of its prime because it kind of happens
cyclically well it's just
you know and i feel like it's there
right i don't
anything i did the biggest thing i hate
about anywhere is watching some place
have the mentality of well we got to
take seats out let's take some seats out
and make that more a premium ticket
yeah [ __ ]
let's work on give me an if like if i
was the ceo and you came in as the cmo
and told me that all right i got it boss
we're going to take seats out and we're
going to make that back you know dayless
deal it'll be way better that way like
you're fired no
i need somebody to tell me how to fill
those seats that i already have that
i've invested in that are there that's
my mentality like there's no chance
that's defeat you know it as a
competitor and you like no way
build your product better make them come
like
it has to be the number one thing to do
in that town you know like there's so
many different things
anywhere in the country that i feel like
you can go but it always again
don't make no mistake about what i'm
saying i'm not saying it's not about the
product at all it is that product has to
be good but you can't always count on it
being perfect i think in our sport
probably more than any other sport you
can manipulate that product more than
you can in other sports you know if you
think about a football game you really
can't change football you're gonna be
screwed if if you go to the nfl and an
nfl fan tell a little bob at the coffee
shop that we're no longer gonna play
with the football we're gonna play with
something else
your product's pretty much screwed with
our sport you can change something
within the car some aerodynamic things a
tire underneath of something as simple
as a tire and drastically affect what a
fan sees on that race track that is
something that is way good about our
sport versus our some competit you know
competition as far as tv and ratings and
things like that go as a fan's
perspective is that how easily you can
change
you know what what you see as a product
on that race track that's something that
i love about our sport over any other
sport
all right well what else do you do for
fun you're retired what else do you do
for fun clint
i've been building fence danica i was
building i froze my ass off no one
builds fence for fun clint no one okay
so i told my buddy he calls this is a
good line and i was like i gotta
remember that he goes uh
what are you doing today i was like man
i'm building this fence i
changed the fence around my longhorns
are having trouble so i built me a
little fence around there and it's a
pain in the ass it was freezing cold
i've got blisters on my hands i'm like
75 000 times yesterday you're asking
yourself what in the hell are you doing
with your life this is what you're doing
you're out here building a fence 42
years old yeah you're building a fence
in the middle of nowhere for some damn
longhorn probably gonna go through and
destroy it anyway that's what you're
doing so he calls and asks me
eric and he says hey what are you doing
that's building a fence you go don't you
have one of those tools like
nah he goes yeah i got a really nice
tool in the house it's called a phone
call somebody that knows how to build a
fence
yeah i mean did you not think to
yourself for just a second
i'm rich i could just hire someone to do
this
i've been building a fence danica that's
what i've been doing but it's kind of my
escape away from it's my protection if
i'm not at my ranch building a fence i'm
out
the week before i was in key west you're
not drinking very productive it wasn't a
very productive week is what i'm trying
to say if you're not building a fence
you're drinking and it's really just
it's helping yourself
yes now you get this age now i hate
running like nobody's chasing me anymore
so there's no really reason to run
you're out here
putting pounds on as you speak like
like i can drink this and put seven
pounds on all of a sudden it's like what
in the hell was that what maybe that's
the problem i feel like i gained some
weight after nascar and i'm like
something's happening i mean now mind
you i have plenty of medical [ __ ] that
i'm dealing with that i that could be
the reason but i'm like maybe it's
because i'm not running marathons every
weekend essentially which is it's not it
can't be that there's got to be a better
answer danica if i have to run marathons
to keep from being
overweight
i guess i'm just going to learn how to
be happy overweight like i'm you just
instead of two chins instead of two
chins i'm gonna have four like that's
just how do you think i wore a
turtleneck
i think you're confused
like i don't know what's going on
your turtleneck screams it's cold
outside and then your your sleeves off
scream that you're in arizona and you're
blistering your ass it's hot like i'm uh
i'm i'm a big ball of duality you know
all ends of the spectrum
well clint i'm really i think this next
chapter of your life becoming uh you
know involved with the sport and helping
the sport to be really cool really
helpful and i just hope you remember the
little people when you are like ceo of
nascar by the way you picked at me for
drinking it went on my time off you
literally have your own booze do you
understand that too yeah two two of your
own businesses that evolve drinking so
do not pick on dipstick
oh yeah by the way readily available
right there
i did a um wait it's right here because
i did this the other night it was like a
caviar wine tasting with my so it's like
this fancy caviar lady she she did
caviar for paris hilton's wedding the
night before and then she did
my little thing the next day and then we
i had wine delivered so these are all my
wines they look really good by the way
thanks you think you'd even like offer
me a sale maybe
three percent off something i should i
should buddy deal i should but you're
gonna have to come to arizona to get it
i'm in i'm in if that means bring your
wife please yes but she'll drink all my
booze she'll drink all the wine
wine what do you call it with caviar do
you is it booze
cause it's gonna call it
by the way by the time they offered
caviar in kansas that's why i don't like
caviar by the time it was offered in
kansas you probably shouldn't try it
a little bit rank
wait one more thing this is just
something to say you don't have to reply
did we even start this thing do you
remember like i don't think we started
no we'll do this tomorrow um then the
next time you go out hunting
i'm you know this is a little
hypocritical because i do eat meat i
just don't like to kill it and i feel
bad when little baby bambi dies so if
you just don't mind drinking too much so
that when you like aim at the target or
bow and arrow or whatever you do with it
you miss blow and arrow at the target
you just just miss just miss one for me
okay or a whole all of them [ __ ] on my
face that is it's for a good reason it's
so i can blend in
to the bush that way i can find that
down at your store two-step or whatever
like oh damn it if you would get me off
this thing however i turn this off in a
minute i'll be back out there and i'm
going hunting as soon as i get off of
this so i appreciate your time this was
playing intense by the way
thanks clint thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the subscribe
button